Harry Kersh: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Subway in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
At Subway in the UK,
you can get sandwiches
in four different sizes.
Firstly, we have toasted bites,
a 6-inch sub,
a foot-long sub,
and then
you can get a platter.
Joe Avella: And in the
US, we have three sizes.
The 6-inch.
The foot-long.
There you go.
For you and your team,
[grunts] the big boy.
Party platter.
The old Subway platypus.
Harry: Now, in the UK, a
platter looks like this.
What they do is they make
four foot-long sandwiches,
then they cut those into fours.
So you're left with 16 pieces,
each of which is 3 inches.
Joe: And for the party platter here,
they take five sandwiches,
cutting them into three pieces,
giving you 15 sandwiches total.
In addition, in the US
you can also get yourself
a 3-foot-long party sub.
[laughs]
Look at this thing!
This is ridiculous.
3 feet, so that is, what that's in...
what do you got in the UK?
That's...17 meters?
I have no idea.
Yeah!
Harry: Now, in the UK, drinks
at Subway come in two sizes.
We have a regular, which
is 400 milliliters.
Joe: 20-ounce Sprite. What up?
Harry: And we have a large.
Joe: 30-ounce. Boom.
And if you're really thirsty,
[laughs]
40 ounces of soda.
40 ounces is a little
over three cans of soda.
That is way too much soda.
It is way too, that's just too much.
Harry: If you're a fan
of Subway's cookies,
in the UK those come in three sizes.
One cookie.
Three cookies.
Or 12 cookies.
Joe: In the US Subway, you
can get a single cookie,
a dozen cookies,
right like that,
or
the [laughs]
hang on, keep rolling,
the 36-cookie platter!
Booyah!
[laughs]
I'm like in Vegas, baby! All in.
Harry: We wanna make
sure that you're getting
the same amount of filling
as you do in the US
here in the UK.
So, what we've got here
is a foot-long Italian BMT
on hearty Italian
with lettuce and olives.
We're gonna weigh it to
see if the quantities
are the same.
Joe: All right, BMT.
Stay.
Harry: So, the weights are pretty similar.
What we're gonna do is take them apart
and see how it all adds up.
So, when it comes to the
amount of filling that you get
in your subs, it looks
like the UK and the US
are actually pretty identical.
So, what about calories?
We found out that the
most popular sub at Subway
is actually the turkey breast sub.
So if you were to walk into a UK Subway
and order a regular turkey breast sub
and then make it a meal by
including a regular drink
and a cookie, you'd be
looking at 621 calories.
Joe: That same order in
the US is 690 calories.
Now, the sub itself is actually
less calories. It's only 250.
But the drink, the medium
Coke, is around 240,
and the cookie is 200 calories.
But wait! According to the internet,
in the US the default actually
comes with two cookies,
which brings it to a grand
total of 890 calories.
Harry: What about the
calories in another sub?
Well, in the UK, 6 inches
of meatball marinara
comes in at 492 calories.
Joe: In the US, 6-inch meatball
is only 430 calories.
Yo.
Harry: Now, because we're
not sure why our meatball sub
is more calorific, we're
actually gonna do another test.
We're gonna bring back
our friend the scales.
And we're gonna weigh a meatball.
Just...
clean that bit.
Delicious.
Boom.
Joe: And now I will
also weigh one meatball.
Gonna find a good one.
Don't want the sauce to
throw off these measurements.
Get in real close. Get
in real close over there.
Ready? You close?
Close? Here we go.
Drumroll.
And...uh!
How much is it?
No change?
Our scale is not very accurate. Sorry.
Let's get that weight up on the screen!
Harry: Unfortunately, Subway in the UK
doesn't disclose the
full ingredients list.
However, there are some things
we can glean from the website.
In the UK, the ham,
turkey breast, and steak
that you'll find in your
sandwiches are actually "formed."
Joe: The turkey bologna
and the turkey salami
are also made by a process known as
mechanically separated turkey.
[typing]
"Mechanically separated
turkey."
What do we got here?
Harry: From the allergens list in the UK,
we can also see that our
meatballs contain milk,
although it's not clear if
the meatballs contain the milk
or if it just comes
with cheese by default.
Joe: We do have the ingredients list
of the meatball sandwich at Subway,
and I'll read that to you right now.
Oh, boy.
Beef, water, breadcrumbs,
and then we have the
kind of square brackets,
[toasted wheat crumbs,
and now we have the curved brackets,
(enriched wheat flour,
now we have the fancy brackets,
{wheat flour, niacin, reduced iron,
thiamine mononitrate,
riboflavin, folic acid},
close fancy brackets,
sugar, salt, soybean oil, yeast)],
and then close the other two brackets.
[clears throat]
Textured soy protein
concentrate, seasoning,
open brackets again,
(dehydrated onion and
garlic, salt, spices,
dehydrated parsley, soybean
oil), close brackets,
soy protein concentrate,
and Romano cheese.
Can you scroll up, please?
Keep going. Keep going.
The Romano cheese,
which is made from pasteurized
"part-skin" cow's milk.
[sighs] I'm assuming
it's "skim" cow's milk.
But to be honest, if I told you
there was cow skin in this
food, would you be surprised?
Part-skim cow's milk,
cheese cultures, salts, and enzymes.
"Which enzymes?" you ask.
They're not at liberty to say,
but rest assured there are enzymes.
Now, on the bright side, the
dough is pretty much normal.
For the classic Italian bread,
the ingredients are enriched flour,
which is wheat flour,
niacin, reduced iron,
thiamine mononitrate,
nitrate? Yeah. OK.
Riboflavin, folic acid,
water, yeast, sugar,
soybean oil, salt, wheat gluten,
cultured wheat flour,
malted barley flour,
sunflower lechithin.
Lecithin.
Leckithin?
Hey, did you hear that?
Phone: Lecithin.
Joe: Lecithin!
Sunflower lecithin, dough conditioner,
which also has enzymes.
Which ones, you don't know.
And ascorbic acid.
[sighs] All that stuff.
Harry: While we might not
have an ingredients list
for our bread, we do know
that it's likely to not be perfect.
For example, an Irish
court recently declared
that Subway cannot call its loaves "bread"
due to the high sugar content.
Subway uses more than
10% sugar in their flour.
Here's everything you
can only find on the menu
at a UK Subway.
So, let's start with the subs.
Now, there are a few kind of default subs
that you can only find in the UK.
So then once you've chosen
your sub and your bread,
we've also got a few other
customization options
that are exclusive to the UK.
For example, in this sub we've
combined a bunch of them.
So, I've gone for chicken tikka.
It has hash browns.
It has sweet corn.
It has vegan garlic aioli.
It has HP brown sauce,
and it has whole-grain mustard.
So, brown sauce is kind of
a traditional British condiment.
The biggest brand manufacturer of it
is a brand called HP,
which stands for Houses of Parliament,
to maybe give a nod --
Joe: Harry, are you really
Brit-splaining to me HP sauce?
I love HP sauce.
I've been having HP sauce,
I've had a bottle of HP sauce in my fridge
for at least the past 20 years.
Harry: Over here, we have the
meatless meatball marinara sub
with some vegan
"mozzarella" cheese as well.
And it's on chili paprika bread.
Joe: Our exclusive
customizations in the US
include avocado, pepper
jack cheese, provolone,
Swiss cheese, and banana peppers.
And if you like your sauce,
you can make your sauce --
[laughs]
If you like a saucy sub,
you can have the sauciest Subway saucy sub
here in the United Sauce,
because we have all these sauces,
including a balsamic sub
sauce, a creamy sriracha,
a deli brown mustard, yellow mustard,
you guys don't have yellow mustard?
That can't be right.
Sorry if you don't have yellow mustard.
I thought that was everywhere.
Oil.
Oil?
You guys don't have oil either?
OK.
Subway herb and garlic oil,
ranch, red wine vinaigrette,
and a special "sub" spice.
Harry: So, moving the subs
to one side for a second,
we also have some side dishes
which are exclusive to the UK.
Let's start with this,
which kind of surprised me
when I saw it on the menu,
but you can actually just get
a cup of meatballs from Subway.
Next we have the garlic cheesy bread,
which I think is just half of
their hearty Italian 6-inch
with some garlic butter on it,
and then they kind of
sprinkle some cheese on top
and throw it in the toaster oven.
The last side dish is nachos.
They actually just get some Doritos,
throw them into a box,
give you some cheese, some jalapeños.
Joe: That is an insult to nachos.
Those are the kind of
nachos you make in your 20s
when you're drunk at 2 in the morning.
Chips, cheese, microwave
it, throw on some salsa.
That is the most depressing
plate of nachos I've ever seen.
That is the worst thing associated,
excuse me, that is the second-worst thing
associated with the Subway franchise.
The only exclusive side that you can get
at a Subway in the US
is the applesauce pouch,
which we don't have.
Unfortunately, the two Subways we went to
did not have them available.
Can we get a graphic
of the applesauce pouch
on the screen somewhere near my head?
Yeah, it looks like that.
Harry: Now, we wanted to
get as many UK exclusives
into one sub as possible.
So this is my creation.
I'll be clear, this is not my usual order.
You get the tang of the brown sauce
with the little popping
sweetness of the sweet corn.
And then I just got, like, a whole
hash brown in there as well.
Do not order the UK Only sub.
Joe: And of course, we put together a sub
with all the USA-only ingredients,
which is a foot-long barbecue rib sandwich
with the jalapeño
cheddar bread and avocado
and pepper jack cheese
and provolone cheese
and Swiss cheese and banana peppers.
Ugh, the US with banana peppers.
I don't know what our thing
is with banana peppers.
I'm not into banana peppers.
I don't know why they're so popular here.
That's actually pretty good.
I actually like that.
The jalapeño bread. Wow!
Oh, man, the sriracha sauce.
Ooh, and the avocado.
Whoa, it's got some heat to it, too.
I'm totally surprised.
I kind of like that.
Yeah!